quisiera preguntarle primero por esta
salida de malí que ha generado
preocupaciones por un eventual
crecimiento del extremismo en la región
ss un escenario posible que cree usted
bueno si pienso que la retirada de
francia es la consecuencia directa de la
crisis y empezó y que iba creciendo es
desde donde el golpe de estado de 2020
gracia
apoyándose en la decisión de la cedeao
había emprendido una serie de
y sanciones
una sanción de que apoyó francia y
después del segundo golpe de estado
mucha amenaza desde el gobierno francés
hacia la junta militar un incremento del
nivel de crisis entre ambos países y eso
es la consecuencia directa de esto cree
usted que es posible además un
fortalecimiento de la presencia y la
influencia de rusia en la región
bueno pienso que rusia el mar y como en
otra parte del mundo ocupa un sitio
y los demás dejan vacío en este caso el
de diferencia porque como se ha visto en
esencia por ejemplo cuando se va la
antigua potencia de una región pues
se inician y entran en la región
bueno y precisamente en este contexto y
sin la participación de malí líderes de
la unión europea y también la unión
africana comenzaron una cumbre de dos
días en bruselas con el objetivo de
mejorar la relación entre ambos bloques
en ámbitos como la seguridad la salud y
la estabilidad y se prevee que del
encuentro salga un plan de acción para
2030 en el que la unión europea-
movilizaría áfrica 150 mil millones de
euros en inversiones públicas y privadas
por su parte el presidente de senegal y
de la unión africana pidió entre otras
cosas mejorar el acceso a las vacunas
contra el virus del cob y 19 en áfrica
un continente donde solamente el 11 por
ciento de la población está totalmente
inoculada señor de regresamos con
ustedes porque bueno estamos como
decíamos ante una suerte de búsqueda de
reinicio de las relaciones entre la
unión europea y áfrica tras la pandemia
por supuesto como cree usted que se han
visto afectada las relaciones durante
todo este periodo
bueno según las cifras de la alianza
popular para la vacunación es una
organización que reúne casi 100
organizaciones de la onu sida y cristian
hate y oxfam
como lo decía muy bien el 11% de la
población afectada ha recibido las dos
primeras dosis y sólo un 30 millones de
dosis han han llegado al continente por
lo que va del año mientras que al final
de mes se va a ir a tirar 55 millones de
dosis en la unión europea así que pienso
que
en este en este marco pues la unión
europea hubiera podido hacer más ya que
han bloqueado el proceso de de sanción
que podía permitir la empresa africana
producir la vacuna de forma genérica
ahora nos queda poco tiempo pero
quisiera preguntarle lo siguiente porque
en el encuentro el líder de la unión
africana pidió mejorar el acceso a las
vacunas contra el cubit 19 la pandemia
dejó en clara evidencia que usted la
asimetría en los vínculos y las
desigualdades también
así porque la vacuna no es tan hecho por
la empresa privada pero con fondo
público y encima con un lucro que impide
el acceso a los países desfavorecidos de
los que los países africanos son un gran
parte para que digamos así que pienso
que esto sí ha mostrado una diferencia
clara entre los países del norte y los
del sur en este asunto para finalizar en
menos de 30 segundos como cree que
avanzarán a partir de ahora los vínculos
entre europa y áfrica
bueno creo que con la presencia o la
presión que está poniendo china y rúsia
la unión europea está revisando su
postura hacia una mejora de estas
relaciones